guten abend aus wien naja ich kann sagen
es ist ein allgemeines phänomen das auch
nicht damals betroffen hat es hatte mal
ein buch gegeben
böse jungs kommen in jedes bett das war
mal so ein buchtitel ja und es ist
natürlich so dass männer die die regeln
brechen so zu sagen ja die bösen die
schlimmen jungs auf viele frauen ein
faszinosum sind so war es auch damals
bei mir
wobei es natürlich so dass es
vielschichtiges nicht einerseits ist es
halt dieses bereinigt also diese diese
stärke die solche männer ausstrahlen
andererseits und das war vor allem bei
mir so ist auch ein bisschen dieser mut
bei instinkt dass man glaubt man muss da
jemanden beschützen der eine schlechte
kindheit habt ja es gibt ja so viele
ursachen
ich bin jetzt schon sehr lange anwältin
und ich kann schon bestätigen dass
männer die ins gefängnis kommen
also von wegen schwerer delikte das
dauert nicht lange bis die ersten briefe
dann war ja kommen
und also sie können sich sozusagen nicht
beklagen über fehlenden zu laufen frauen
also manche ich habe ihnen einen
serienmörder vertreten der mann wirklich
wäschekörbeweise briefe bekommen
danach weiß man ja dieser mensch hat
jemanden umgebracht hat ein leben
beendet hat man da auch mit seinem
gewissen und zwischendrin all diese
romantischen gedanken ich möchte ihn
retten und er wird mich beschützen weil
seite und denkt sich was mach ich da
eigentlich so was wie es völlig
ausgeblendet das war auch bei mir so ich
hab das völlig ausgeblendet das war
sozusagen ja das war in der in der
frühen jugend und er hatte drogen
genommen das wird weg geblendet und das
ist auch jetzt so wenn ich so viele
beobachter an das denken die frauen
wobei man natürlich schon auch sagen
muss ist ja auch richtig nicht man muss
ja den täter von der tat beenden weil
das ist ein allgemeines problem dass
leute das immer vermengen das habe ich
auch als strafverteidigerin immer das
problem wenn ich einem besonders
schlimmen vertrete
dass man der meinung ist ich vertrete
diese tat also dass ich das befürworten
würde was natürlich nicht der fall ist
man muss also schon tränen zwischen dem
täter selbst also den menschen und die
tat tatsächlich begangen hat
frau wagner im sommer zum verstehen
vielleicht bin ich da als man nicht ganz
auf dem richtigen posten ich würde es
noch ein bisschen mehr verstehen wollen
irgendwie was macht den reiz aus was
machten mörder zumindest nicht allgemein
aber zumindest in ihrem fall und jetzt
in anderen aktuellen fällen offenbar
sexy offenbar anziehend ist ein
vielschichtiges phänomen zusammenfassend
glaube ich kann man es mit dem reiz des
verbotenen regelbuch auch der ausbruch
aus der normalität ja es ist also
durchaus faszinierend und es wird wohl
auch ein bisschen dieses mütterlich eine
rolle spielen wobei muss schon sagen es
hat in österreich eine sehr attraktive
mörderin gegeben die eis lady und als es
umgekehrt nicht der sehr sehr viele
briefe anlage vor von männern
also es gibt es auch umgekehrt gibt
weniger weibliche täter aber umgekehrt
gibt es das phänomen genau so
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren